Kiersten you just got your star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame as well one of
them before cuz Simon got his night I
spoke at his not he's like it's crazy I
you know honestly I would feel I don't
know I feel weird about me being on a
girl I don't know I Hollywood feel me I
know which I was I would wake up with
anxiety like every day for a week cuz I
hate public speaking I was very nervous
yeah so the morning of like I did have a
glass of wine at like 10:30 in the
morning which I don't think I've never
done I needed it and then was very
silent in the car it was just it's very
hot and like it's just an emotional you
have everyone who you love there it's
almost like a wedding or a funeral too
in a way yeah it's just very intense and
you're giving two very different
functions but yes yeah yeah but just
unless you're marrying someone you don't
want a man we went to Musso and Frank's
after which is a very classic Hollywood
place if you haven't been goin you know
I don't go out I understand so well I
like I said I only go out when I have
like a thing to do so I like we had
Marty I didn't even eat then either I
was just feeding my son spaghetti and
pounding martinis with all our friends
and family we actually almost got
married - we almost called a justice of
the peace
who's going to Frank's because we were
all there already and like we hadn't
made it official yet so we almost did
that but we couldn't get it in time oh
my gosh that's crazy I love y'all yeah
after you got your star a news outlet
tweeted this is amazing that you were
best known as spider-man's girl for yeah
yeah which I was like I mean a great
shot
[Applause]
no now I think you think that's like
Meryl Streep's best is like you know
death becomes a which is great I love
that maybe out of Africa or Sophie's
Choice it's just it was just so it's
just weird too because I like just say
Mary Jane at least or something it's
like the girlfriend yeah I remember the
second Spiderman it was like the poster
was my face and spider-man's face like
they know I mean I'm like but yeah it
was it was nice though that everyone
came to my back I know I really
appreciated that he actually came to
your defense in a very funny way it's
whitter blew up with people going after
how sexist that was here's one tweet it
said Kirsten Dunst could do once upon a
time but Leonardo DiCaprio couldn't do
bring it on actually think those things
well I didn't like how all the treats
cuz there are tons of tweets like
defending you about that well I didn't
like how they were negative against the
guys cuz those guys are really talented
at the same time that never happens to
God no it always happens to women I like
beating a dead horse compared to each
other men either you never compare them
and we're always being compared I know I
don't understand this is it because
we're so awesome
[Applause]
because they do that with women and
music as well and because you'll just
don't matter and they we do I'm just
gonna filter it that way I'm just anyway
but how did you feel like I always feel
really good when my fans coming right
because they went after people I do -
are you kidding me I was like oh thank
you like it feels so nice to be
appreciated for your work and I have
been doing this for so long and and so a
longer than just Spyder exactly so there
was 3 years old so that's like people
are like your greatest thing was from
Justin to Kelly I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this